the place beyond the pines is a damn
near perfect film I [ __ ] love this
movie it rocked my [ __ ] I loved almost
every second of it this movie is far
beyond ambitious I love story time that
will challenge the traditional views of
what an audience is used to a movie
that's brave enough to try something new
and manages to succeed this film is
essentially divided into three chapters
the first story is about the beautiful
Ryan Gosling he's an exceptional but
broke motorcyclist who wanted discovers
that his ex girlfriend gave birth to his
child so what does the man do to provide
he does with any guy would you rob banks
Ryan Gosling is one of my absolute
favorite actors I would totally suck his
dick he is far beyond electric in this
film he has this incredible ability
especially in this movie to emit so much
emotion with just his stare look at that
photo he's an actor who's not afraid to
expose himself and be different there's
great performances throughout but by far
he has the best performance in this
movie and he has the best chapter in
this movie have you come across any
idiot who tells you oh it's just like
driving except with a motorcycle don't
listen to that punch them in the face
cut their throat and tell them that's
why you're an idiot I was also
especially surprised by ever Mendes I
usually just enjoy her performances and
her tits but this has got to be the most
raw most real performance I've seen of
her yet the second chapter focuses on a
cop played by Bradley Cooper a hero who
finds himself caught in between fellow
crooked cops Bradley Cooper is brilliant
in this role he is the perfect
comparison to Gosling there's similar
enough an age in someone in appearances
and it just made sense for a Gosling
that he cast as the bank robber and for
Cooper to be cast as a cop plus he feels
like a real cop you too can emit so much
emotion without having to say much and
you can truly feel this internal
struggles there's some great supporting
work in here from Rose Byrne is Bradley
Cooper's wife from Ben Mendelsohn you
might remember him as Daggett from the
Dark Knight Rises and Ray Liotta
the main dirty cop and it's one array
Leona's best performances in years plus
his botox not so distracting anymore if
I were to tell you what the third
chapter is about it would be a big
spoiler so instead I'll just say that
one of the main characters is played by
this actor he does a superb job this is
not a film it's only great because of
its performances the script is
absolutely amazing and ambitious the way
they transition into each chapter and
the three stories they chose to tell is
so perfectly unique and entailed Derek
Cianfrance directing this movie was just
as brave as the script itself there's a
wonderful opening sequence that
perfectly lays out the tone and style of
this movie the bank robbery scenes are
shot with such brilliance they feel so
real there's also some wonderful
cinematography in this film as well as
exceptional music if you like dramas
then you'll love don't place beyond the
pines let me get straight to the point
here all in all i gotta say the place
beyond the pines got its super right
you
alright guys thanks for checking out the
video please go ahead and scrolls in a
comment box and tell me your points
below and if you want to see a more
in-depth review of the place beyond the
pines go ahead and check out my show
called reasons to see that I do with my
buddy Jerry will give you reasons to see
and not to see the place beyond the
pines and last but not least if you like
what you saw in you want to get updated
every time a new review is out go ahead
and subscribe to my channel on the link
right there